DAN GALPIN: Hello.
I'm Dan Galpin for
"The Developer Show."
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Firebase in-app messaging
is now available.
It will help you
guide active app users
by sending them targeted
and contextual messages.
Take a look at the post
linked in the description
below for this and several
other updates across Firebase,
including the addition
of change history
with Remote Config, Crashlytics
integrations, and more.
The Wear app review
process, in place
since the launch of
Android Wear 2.0,
will soon become mandatory.
New apps listed on
the Wear OS by Google
version of the Google Play
Store will require review
beginning in October of 2018,
while updates to existing apps
will require review
beginning of March of 2019.
For details, take
a look at the post.
You can now author
Cloud Functions
that use headless
Chrome and utilize
all the features
of a web browser
in a fully serverless
environment.
Use cases include
taking screenshots
of web pages, server-side
rendering, implementing web
crawlers, and more.
Example code is on the post.
Earlier this year,
Google's Project Zero team
disclosed serious
security flaws rooted
in speculative execution.
Spectre and Meltdown
were the first instances
of these attacks.
And now Intel has
published details
on a new set of speculative
execution vulnerabilities.
Head on over to
the post to learn
how to mitigate guest control
entries not controlled
by the host OS and what steps
you may need to take to ensure
you're fully protected.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Dan Gapin for
"The Developer Show."
This is your update on the
coolest developer "noogle."
Leh. (SLURRING)
This is your update.
All right.
Try it one more time.
SPEAKER 2: "Noogles."
DAN GALPIN: "Noogles."
(SLURRING) This is your update.
All right.
[LAUGHS]